[Music]
we know these people
you know the almighty anime characters
who rarely if ever
lose as expected these characters have
often garnered a more polarized
reception
specifically in a certain role on the
more serious shows that aren't obvious
parodies nonetheless i'd love to talk
about these characters and we'll be
doing it right now
before i get started i want to let you
know i'm going to be doing this in a
more random way
given the nature of the topic this will
not be a power level debate
because reasonably speaking how can you
put an unstoppable force and an
immovable object with wildly varying
powers and scaling
we start with tatsuyashiba
the oni sama meme was in full bloom back
when mahoka's first season aired and
having updated myself with the novels
all the way to the end
i'd say that status quo is here to stay
the funny thing about mahoga is that it
tries to put our protagonist as an
underdog early on with their admission
systems classifying him as a weed and a
regular a lesser magician in layman
terms
he had little talent and all oh how
those systems failed
horribly underneath the slow casting
speed in which his status as an
irregular is determined
lies one of the most genius magical
engineers in the world of majorca his
skills are analyzing and countering
anything are just impeccable he can even
bring himself and other people back to
life
i mean this is a guy who beat a sniper
with his trusty handgun for god's sake
with the same handgun eradicates an
entire terrorist organization in their
hideout
how about vaporizing an entire army from
the safety of his military base
like what he did in the season's first
climax yeah that's right
all hail tatsuya
[Music]
now before we resume our list of
characters who never lose
why don't you try taking the role of one
of those characters the power is yours
thanks to today's sponsor aura kingdom
become the protagonist of your story and
reach unthinkable heights with this hit
mmorpg aura kingdom is an anime rpg that
takes you to the colorful world of
azuria
as an envoy of gaia players can then
choose to be one of the 17 classes in
order to explore the world
clear dungeons with friends and test
their wits against the unstoppable
monsters that lie in the world
however exploring dungeons and defeating
bosses isn't everything you can do
with over 2 000 costumes and similarly
plenty of customization options
you can let your creativity run wild
with designing your house or your
character
aura kingdom features some of the best
and most well-designed
pet systems that i've known in an mmo
you don't see this kind of longevity
out of a game often and it's a testament
to the game's constant evolution and
creativity
so what are you waiting for come join
the fun it's never too late to hop in
and be a part of the aura kingdom
and all you need to do is to follow the
link below a world of adventure awaits
and i hope to see you soon future envoys
why stop with one dengeki bunko lead
when you can have two
introducing are not voldigoed in the
midst of the jam-packed and blockbuster
laid in summer 2020 season is a hidden
gem
misfit of demon king academy as people
have pointed out it's the one punch man
of these magic fantasy light novels it's
a show that revels in its ridiculousness
and a lot of that has to be in its
portrayal of the league character anos
we're talking about a demon lord
so strong that he got so bored of
winning and just allowed himself to be
sealed
only to reawaken thousands of years
later to a vastly different world which
he so easily dominates and brings to his
knees anyway
disposition wise anna's kind of reminds
me of tatsuya just with more gloating
and a dose of relishing in his strength
as a character
he does have his hidden depths though
and he's definitely a demon lord you'd
want on your side
this is a guy who won't die when he's
killed
literally just ask all the foolish
characters who dare become his enemies
in the show
from light novels we move on to shonen
manga and one of the coolest teachers
you can have
goro sensei there's a lot of things to
like about assassination classroom
it's quirky has a unique plot and has
some good plot developments that made it
such a beloved shonen one thing that
people might notice about goro sensei is
just how overpowered he is
i personally like goro sensei for a lot
of things besides his strength but just
how strong and undefeatable he is is
certainly a topic for discussion
this is an alien thing that partially
destroys the moon and is set on a
collision course with the destruction of
earth first day in class
and we already see that those claims
weren't things of legends he's as
overpowered as they come
and all of a sudden the student's main
quest seems a lot more daunting than
they all actually expected
assassinating this alien octopus is
virtually an impossible task
and that's why i put chorus sensei on
this list
[Music]
ah who doesn't know my hero academia i'm
pretty sure that whole lot of you are
familiar with the series already as well
as its themes of friendship
acceptance and a lot more while the
students and most teachers go through
their share of trials and tribulations
in this series one hero stands above
them as the
ultimate beacon of justice the
infallible all might
the number one ranked hero and the
coolest teacher surrogate father you
could possibly get
yeah it's pretty much impossible for all
mike to lose in the series
even though he came really close at some
point most notably
his ultimate battle against all for one
for me what makes
all my such a great character as far as
unbeatable ones go is how honest his
powers are
there's no broken reality warping thing
or talking someone back to life there's
nothing like that
he's just someone who fights with all
his heart and passion sure some
depiction of his powers can be a little
bit over the top
but we get nothing close to the
ridiculous of say annose
27-0 all 27 wins are as a result of a ko
the record that speaks for itself and
takamura has all the reason in the world
to be called the almighty
a nickname that he had also deservingly
earned over his conquest of the multiple
boxing divisions in hajime no ippo
besides the track record there's no
doubt that dakamura is just a fighter
who overflows with charisma he's loud
brash and incredibly cocky but beneath
that loudness
lies in ambitious and occasionally
socially awkward guy
who's had some quite bad luck with the
ladies for me the most admirable trait
of his is his heart and determination
has carried him to that 27-0 record
as i said never underestimate the heart
of a champion and you can see that play
out in full
when you watch some of the most epic
encounters in the series such as that
fierce battle against eagle
jordan picking within jojo's amazing
gallery of broken characters was
actually quite hard but once i trimmed
the list down to characters who barely
lost
the choice became that much easier enter
giorno from the franchise's golden wind
saga
now why would this guy be a character
who barely lost despite more impactful
characters having their fair share of
defeats
now i think that it's largely to do with
this extremely versatile and powerful
stand
gold experience for the untrained eye
seems like an underwhelming stand
mainly used to produce plants and small
animals however
therein lies its power for it has the
power to govern over
life itself that's already an amazing
power to complement to furious close
combat abilities of gold experience
but things get turned up to 11 when it
gets upgraded into gold
experience requiem talk about the
reality warping powers that i've long
lorded anime for
where else can you see an ability that
causes a death loop yep that's right
gianno belongs here and you might want
to check out golden wind to see him in
action
[Music]
the title of world's strongest vampire
is something that often gets handed in
various vampire anime
you see people calling someone strongest
vampire there strongest vampire that
personally i think the one who lives up
to that title the most is none other
than helsing's alucard
he does not mess around and instead of
giving you a rundown of his plethora of
broken abilities
i'll just ask you to watch helsinki and
see his glory in action alucard just
systematically breaks down his enemies
with
sheer unrestrained violence he's every
two thousand
edgy kids wet dream just looking at the
aesthetics the badassness
and the personality in all seriousness
though i put our luck out on this list
because as a character
he's more than just the violence or the
badass powers he has a surprising amount
of depth put into his personality
and he does have some endearing traits
to make helsing ultimate such a delight
to watch
so why not complete the trifecta of
overpowered light novel leads
with their legion of admirers who look
up to them at every turn
sorry kirito you should have won all of
your fights anyway i could call overlord
and iron's highlight ruler for one two
with just how much power he showed in
the series yeah it's a given that he
never loses his fight but what about his
one man army moments his fight with
charltier which he won despite being at
a disadvantage
well there's the time he effortlessly
decimated an entire army with magic
much like what datsuya did is
differentiates himself from the rest of
the overpowered light novel heroes in
his morality
yeah i mean i'd say he's not a
completely evil bad guy per se
even if he straddles that line very very
precariously but this is a person
who doesn't play nice at all the title
overlord is just perfect for someone
like eins but it's called
underneath that immoral skeleton body
you still find the slightest tinge of
humanity from the time he was an
ordinary gamer
now if you were to ask me which
jiu-jitsu kaizen character made the
biggest mark in the anime community the
runaway winner would have to be gojo
not only did his feature episodes and
his last minute saves blow the community
up all the time he always won his
battles with style and flair
i'm not sure whether i like his battle
with jogo or the appearance during the
show's equivalent to a tournament arc
better but it's not like it matters
though is it
both instances were crowning moments and
some of the signature scenes that people
will
always remember jujutsu kaizen for and
it all came in the hands of the
laid-back reverse karkashi to boot
curses everywhere have all the right to
be afraid of this all-powerful sorcerer
who's also one of the best mentors that
our upstarts could ever hope to have
with how jiu-jitsu kaizen is i don't see
gojo's undefeated record being shattered
any time soon the best thing the
villains can do is hold him back
or see his powers or something like that
it's gonna take no less than the final
boss of the entire series
to possibly give him his first decisive
defeat and i personally like it that way
of course zytham has to find his way to
this list he's the all-powerful
one-punch man
after all the ultimate hero capable of
defeating enemies with a single punch
saitama's the whole antithesis of the
whole idea that hard work hardly works
take that shown in protagonists with
destined one status i wouldn't say that
saitama's my favorite amongst these
listed characters but i think the one
punch man as a series has done a great
job in pioneering a never-before-seen
parody of the shonen genre i'm sure it's
not the only one
out there but it sure is the one that
helped anime explode into the public eye
after what attack on titan did a few
years prior
it also helps that within the comedic
and parodying nature of one punch man
by several well-woven stories full of
tearjerkers and awesome moments that
make you go yeah
if you haven't done so yet please watch
the first season of one punch man
feast your eyes on its awesome animation
epic fights
and some surprisingly emotional moments
the list ends there but i want to know
who your favorite undefeated characters
are let's have a talk in the comment
section and we can probably discuss
about some honorable mentions that i
didn't mention if you enjoyed the video
please like the video by clicking the
thumbs up
subscribe and try checking out my other
videos too this channel has a lot of
countdown videos but if you actually
prefer the more video essay-like ones
you can check out my other channel
vinniechukai it mostly has videos about
popular shows like attack on titan or
sword art online but recently
i also started branching off to more
underrated shows that you might be able
to enjoy
such as the latest video on gosick i've
also got memberships and patreon so if
you want to support the channel
financially
i'd be really glad don't forget to check
out our sponsors game
or a kingdom links in the description a
world of adventure awaits
and i hope to see you soon future envoys
thanks for watching and i hope you had
fun
see you next time
[Music]
you